getting rich is fun in the future oh hey
Bobby
Satan thank you so much for being on my
tub are you able to call this a show
well it's on the Internet does that make
it a show of course what a lovely set
they've provided you with I brought you
here to be more famous on the Internet
well I I have to say with billion of
loyal followers I am just not getting
the comments and likes that I would like
to get what do you mean by that I feel
like everyone thinks I bought my
followers did you yeah well some of them
let's see the first thing you need to
know is that gaining followers is easy
I'm listening
the second thing you need to know is
that money can't buy everything but what
content really tests the best with
audiences in 2016 just post a video of
an innocent person being murdered and
enjoy the advertising revenue praise
Jesus
making money on the internet it's a
beautiful thing
Satan thank you so much for being on my
show
[Music]